hello and welcome to this talk from the
Yale child stay
our anxiety disorders program in today's
talk will look at cognitive behavioral
therapy for child and adolescent anxiety
disorders and at how to successfully
implement that treatment with children
suffering from anxiety cognitive
behavioral therapy or CBT has garnered
considerable support over the past years
as an effective evidence-based treatment
for childhood anxiety disorders but what
goes into actually doing a CBT and what
are the kinds of things a child is
likely to experience over the course of
treatment one helpful way of thinking
about what goes on in cognitive
behavioral therapy for anxiety is to
imagine the child progressing along to
related but also separate pathways one
pathway is that of acquiring skills for
better regulating anxiety and better
managing anxiety in situations which
provoke fear think of the child is
creating a kind of imaginary toolbox
from which to draw when faced with an
anxiety provoking situation the other
pathway is that of exposure and
desensitization by this we refer to the
process of gradually bringing the child
into more and more direct contact with
the situations and stimuli that cause
fear and that they've been avoiding
exposure and desensitization are an
important part of CBT for anxiety and
we'll talk about them in another lecture
but what are some of the skills that a
child is likely to learn over the course
of CBT think of the four component model
of anxiety including the cognitive
behavioral emotional and physiological
aspects of the anxious response if
exposures and desensitization target the
behavioral component of anxiety then the
other skills will all target the
remaining manifestations of anxiety so
the child's toolbox will include three
compartments for the emotional cognitive
and physiological signs of anxiety a
number of skills target the cognitive
element of anxiety and one of the most
important is that of cognitive
restructuring by
this we mean the process of teaching a
child to identify those thoughts that
are stemming from the anxiety disorder
and that caused them to experience more
anxiety the child will learn to identify
those thoughts and to challenge them by
asking questions about the accuracy of
the of the thought or the truthfulness
of what anxiety is telling them and
they'll also learn to formulate
alternative cognitions or other thoughts
that could compete with those coming
from their anxiety disorder for example
a child with social anxiety disorder who
is having lunch in a school cafeteria
might see some children laughing at a
nearby table and might automatically
have the thought they're laughing at me
that thought stemming from the anxiety
disorder is likely to cause increased
distress and anxiety and will increase
the probability that the child will
avoid the public lunchroom in the future
in cognitive restructuring the child
will learn to ask questions such as is
it really certain that they're laughing
at me or does every child who's laughing
have to be laughing at me even a child
with a significant anxiety disorder is
likely to be able to recognize that not
all laughter has to be directed at them
and could then be encouraged to
formulate alternative cognitions such as
they might be laughing at a joke they
shared where maybe they're remembering
something funny that happened earlier
even if the child isn't yet ready to
believe that those alternative
hypotheses are the correct ones just by
identifying the thought as coming from
anxiety and by formulating these
possible alternatives the child is
already making progress and will be able
to draw from that experience in future
anxiety provoking situations in other
examples a child with
obsessive-compulsive disorder might have
the thought mommy will die if I don't
tap the table four times and can be
taught to identify that as coming from
obsessive-compulsive disorder and to
challenge it with questions such as how
could that even work and the child could
formulate an alternative such as that's
just my OCD talking
or a child with panic disorder who has
the thought I'm dying
when they feel their heart racing could
be taught to come up with an alternative
such as this is just the signs of my
panic disorder it's just anxiety in
treatment a therapist might ask a child
to chart and even journal their anxious
thoughts over the course of a week they
will identify the thoughts coming from
anxiety and formulate alternatives with
a younger child this kind of cognitive
restructuring might take the form of
play such as an imaginary boxing match
between anxiety and logic
by taking the role of logic the
therapist can model to the child the
kind of alternatives that the child will
then be able to use when formulating
alternatives to their own anxious
thought so for example a young child
might say to the therapist you're going
to get very sick taking the role of
anxiety and the therapist representing
logic might respond with statements such
as I might get sick but how certain is
that to happen or if I get sick I'll be
uncomfortable for a while and then I'll
get better or even my parents can take
care of me if I get unwell another skill
that fits into the cognitive compartment
of the anxiety toolbox is that of using
the imagination or guided imagery to
reduce anxiety children parents and even
therapists are often astounded at the
power of imagination
in lowering anxiety but it helps to keep
in mind that anxiety is really coming
from imagination in the first place
after all
anxiety is all about imagining bad
things happening so it makes sense to
combat anxiety in its own natural domain
there are any number of ways to use the
imagination to lower anxiety a lot of
them focus on helping a child to
visualize the thought that's provoking
the anxiety growing more and more
distant children can do this for example
by imaginary a field perhaps a green
filled with trees all around and smell
of freshly cut grass in the air and a
light breeze
and a blue sky overhead and then the
child can be encouraged to imagine a
hot-air balloon
gently drifting over the field and the
child could place their anxious thought
in the basket under the hot air balloon
and watch as it slowly drifts away from
them growing more and more distant until
it's only a tiny speck of color on the
blue sky when the hot-air balloon
disappears completely from view taking
the anxiety thought with it it's often
remarkable how much the anxiety has gone
down other ways to visualize a thought
going more and more distant could be for
example a child thinking of their own
mind as a kind of crowded train station
with people jostling about and trains
pulling in and bringing with them
anxious thoughts even a young child can
understand that standing on the tracks
of a train station and trying to block a
train from coming in is not a healthy
strategy but they can also be taught
that you don't need to block the train
because if you just wait a minute or two
all trains will eventually pull out of
the station and leave taking the anxious
thought with them and they can watch as
again the thought grows further and
further in the distance or even just
imagining the zoom of a camera lens
which could be narrowly focused on
whatever is provoking the anxiety but
could also draw back to a wider angle so
that they anxious trigger gets smaller
and smaller in the child's imagination
other skills will target the
physiological compartment of the anxiety
toolbox by practicing relaxation
exercises children can both lower their
anxiety in the moment and also reduce
the probability of experiencing
heightened anxiety over the course of
the day the two skills most commonly
taught in cognitive behavioral therapy
for anxiety are progressive muscle
relaxation and diaphragmatic breathing
progressive progressive muscle
relaxation is taught by encouraging a
child to consecutively focus on
different parts of their body perhaps
starting from the feet moving up through
the legs and stomach and shoulders neck
and face
face and arms and hands to focus on each
muscle group in turn and try to relax it
so that by the end of the exercise the
entire body is loose calm and relaxed
diaphragmatic breathing is taught by
encouraging a child to inhale slowly
through the nose while allowing the
belly to expand to make room for the
lungs and the air and then to exhale
slowly through the mouth while allowing
the belly to sink back in as the lungs
contract this kind of diaphragmatic
breathing is a powerful signal to the
brain that everything is safe and even
one or two minutes of successfully
breathing in this way can bring about
dramatic reduction in anxiety for some
children though relaxation exercises
seem to have an almost paradoxical
effect leading to increased anxiety
perhaps this is because a child who
experiences himself as being at risk
might see relaxation as a kind of
lowering of the defenses and feel more
vulnerable and hence more anxious
children who feel this way will often be
reluctant to engage in relaxation and
might become irritable or anger when you
are angry when encouraged to do so when
this happens it might be most helpful to
just choose another tool from the
anxiety toolbox but for some children
taking an almost opposite approach
tensing up their whole body focusing on
all those same muscle parts and holding
them tight and taut like a spring for 30
or 60 seconds and then letting go is a
way of achieving relaxation without
trying to directly combat the child's
tendency to tenseness and rigidity the
emotional compartment of the anxiety
toolbox is that least frequently
targeted by therapists in cognitive
behavioral therapy however some helpful
skills can fit into this compartment as
well one helpful principle is that of
competing emotions or the idea that it's
hard for a child to experience two very
different feelings at the same time this
is of course a problem
and anxiety and fear make it hard for a
child to experience positive emotions
but it can also be a tool that can that
the child can use for example by
encouraging a child to actively elicit a
feeling other than fear the experience
of fear can be reduced some children may
be able to do this by making themselves
laugh and experiencing mirth or humor
one little girl chose to do this by
changing the scene that she perpetually
had in her mind of her father being hurt
in a car accident into the set of a
movie about a car accident in which her
father was starring and this amused her
so that she was less anxious another
child made a picture of his mother in
the hospital connected to tubes but then
wrote on the picture that the tubes were
filled with chocolate milk and made
themselves laugh for some children
however humor might seem a little out of
reach when they're experiencing a lot of
anxiety and other emotions might be more
attainable for example a child could
actually actively elicit anger and
channel that anger at the anxiety
disorder young children could make a
kind of sock puppet that represents
their anxiety disorder and could get
really angry at the anxiety and hit it
or yell at it when they feel that
anxiety is acting up as they get angry
or at their fear they also feel less
afraid and so over the course of
cognitive behavioral therapy children
will learn a set of skills that they can
draw from when experiencing anxiety and
they'll also undergo a series of
exposures to achieve desensitization
successfully planning and executing
exposure and desensitization is the
topic of another talk in this series
thank you
you